[Musique]
George Herbert Walker Bush était le
dernier grand soldat américain, homme d'État, un
père fondateur du 20e siècle pour servir, il
devait réussir pour présider, il devait l'emporter
[Musique]
cette initiative historique de
réunification allemande n'aurait jamais pu
réussir sans le brillant
leadership du président  Bush, je crois qu'on
dira qu'aucun occupant du
Bureau Ovale n'était plus courageux, plus
fondé sur des principes et plus honorable que
George Herbert. Walker Bush, la
personne la plus décente et la plus honorable que j'aie jamais
rencontrée était mon ami George Bush, l'un des
hommes nobles de la nature, quand on m'a dit qu'il
si le ministre était en direct, je l'ai appelé, j'ai dit
papa, je t'aime et tu as été un
père merveilleux
et les derniers mots qu'il dirait sur
terre si je t'aime aussi
le meilleur père qu'un fils ou une fille puisse
avoir et dans notre chagrin mais un  sourire
sachant que papa serre Robin dans ses bras et
tient à nouveau la main de maman
[Musique]